hi i'm sriji shirakara
i'm going to talk about excluding ph
patient
this is a joint work with raffle samsung
let me start by explaining the very
influential gerber of impergazu he
classified five possible words that are
consistent with with our current
knowledge here you have
five possibles from algorithmical up to
cryptomania and for example algorithmic
is a world where p is equal to lp
the rest of words corresponds to a verb
in which p is different from np
and these are further classified in this
way
cryptomania is a world where there is a
public key cryptosystem
personnel is the worst possible world
and this in this world it's impossible
to construct a secretary cryptosystem
and also it is impossible to
solve lp on average
mini crypto is a world where it's
impossible to construct a public
decryptor system but it's possible to
construct a secret decrypter system
heuristical is a world where
there are efficient heuristics for np
but it's
um
but np is hard in the worst case
so these are five possible words and the
ultimate goal of compressed story is to
decide which words corresponds to our
world
in particular most researchers believe
that our world is a cryptomania
so the goal is to show that our world is
created many
but unfortunately there are few progress
on this question and the researchers
have made little progress so far
so what we do in this work is to propose
a way to make progress
before explaining the idea let me
mention that the existence of a secret
decryptor system is equivalent to the
existence of a cylinder generator as
well as a one-way function
so we are going to use this
definition
in this work we would like to propose to
study ph versions of the five possible
worlds
remember that p8
stands for polynomial hierarchy and this
is a generalization of nlp
usually when we consider five possible
words we consider polynomial time
computable public key crypto or
polynomial time computable pseudonym
generators
but
ph in the ph versions of five plus words
we consider ph computer republican
crypto or ph computable p serum
generators and so forth
in the original version of five possible
words there is a significant implication
to cryptography
but our version
has no implications to cryptography
unfortunately but we believe that these
possible words are completely
theoretically interesting
our main result about the ph versions of
five possible worlds is that we were
able to unconditionally rule out ph
patients
specifically we were able to show the
equivalence between the existence of a
ph computer with pseudonym generator and
averages hardness of ph
as a consequence of this equivalence we
can show that this statement is false
and
therefore we can exclude ph patient
we believe that this result is
conceptually interesting because if we
consider ph heuristica we still don't
know whether we can exclude ph
heuristica or not
moreover if we consider ph algorithmic
it's actually equivalent to the standard
version of algorithmic so even if we
consider ph buttons of five possible
world it doesn't so
trivial to exclude this world but in the
case of a ph patient we were able to
exclude it unconditionally
let me mention previous work on ph
patient
in my previous work we showed that ph is
held on average if and only if
documented ph is held in the last case
here japan katie's ph is a problem of
approximating ph oracle time bound to
chroma complexity
and moreover we were able to show that
these
conditions are equivalent to the
existence of a ph computer heating
center generator
in particular this result means that
excluding phd heuristic is actually
equivalent to probing nlp hardness of a
gap-mediated ph which is still open
um
in the previous work we
actually used the notion of hilarious
averages notion which is denoted by
average p but
in this work we instead investigate era
from averages compressed of ph which is
denoted by spp
let me state our result more formally
if we consider ph patient there are at
least two ways to define it
so we can consider uniform adversaries
or non-in-home adversaries
we were able to unconditionally rule out
both of these versions of a ph specimen
more broadly not only we exclude ph
patient we can present equivalence
between several statements for example
the existence of ph configurable
synthetic
is equivalent to the
averages hardens of ph and it is
moreover equivalent to the averages
hardness of minka did ph
um this means that the main category ph
is distribution of ph complete even in
an error prone case
whereas the previous box shows
distribution ph completeness in an
errors case
now let me state our result in the
knowing homo case
we can prove the following equivalent
the first statement says that ph is
averages hard with respect to the uni
home distribution against polynomial
size circuit
the second condition shows that minikit
is ph its averages had with respect to
the uniform distribution so this means
that mean gate is ph its average is
complete for ph
we can also saw that this is equivalent
to the existence of a ph computable
surrounding generator which extends its
seed by one bit
and if you have our serum and generator
which extended seed by one bit we can
extend seed more
we can show that it is equivalent to
polynomial stretch ph computer pseudonym
generator
so our result shows that error prone
averages hardness of ph is equivalent to
ph computable serum generator
in contrast to this the previous work
shows the equivalence between hilarious
averages hardness ph and ph computable
heating set generator
so the difference between cellular
generator and heating cytogenetics are
essentially equivalent to the difference
between error-prone averages harmonious
memory qrp
and errors averages hardness over ph
namely ability p
in the case of uniform case we can prove
a quite similar result
namely we can show that
averages hardness of ph is equivalent to
the existence of ph computer surround
generator
which extends the seed by one bit which
is secure against bpp
but when we try to stretch the seed more
we haven't been able to do this
what we can get is that it is also
equivalent to the existence of ph
computable serum generator that extends
the seed
by order logan bits
beyond that we are not able to improve
the equivalence but we can also prove
the following
either there is a ph computable surround
generator fits extended seed by
polynomial amount
or there is a target in ph which is
heard in the worst case
so um it's interesting open question
whether we can extend
the stretch more
namely is the existence of a polynomial
storage ph computable solar generator
equivalent to averages hardness of ph in
that case of uniform algorithm
algorithms
to conclude this talk
we believe that
by studying ph
versions of five first world we might be
able to gain some new insight into the
original version so in particular we
believe that our result might hint an
approach towards excluding the standard
patient
and probably the meta complexity of
time-bounded hormone compressive namely
mean kd would play a central role in
excluding personnel
because we showed that make it is ph is
this
distribution ph complete
there are several open questions one
open question is whether we can improve
the equivalence between a polystyrene ph
computer prt against uni home adversary
are
equivalent to averages hardness of ph
another
probably more interesting question is to
exclude ph minicrypt
in order to answer this question we must
formulate ph mini crypto in a
theoretically interesting way and we
need to exclude ph mini crypt
by doing so
we believe that it's it's possible to
gain some new insight into the standard
version of infographics 5 world
thank you for listening